i mean hitler is such a horrible person
to bring up because mussolini you know
yeah mussolini is better
because hitler is so closely connected
to the atrocities of the holocaust right
there's all the stuff that led up to the
war and the war itself say that there
was no
uh holocaust hitler will probably be
viewed differently
i should yes i should think so well i
mean
but you think that's a very
controversial stance you think hitler be
viewed differently if it wasn't for the
holocaust
well i mean
but it's a funny thing that the the the
i would say the death of how many
40 50 million i mean i don't know how
you calculate it
as is not seen as as bad as the 6
million oh yeah because of mountain and
stalin
yeah yeah and but it's interesting
uh working on it you're working yeah the
next book i'm talking reminding well
it's good
i'm i'm i'm glad a good writer is
because no one's not reminded
my last book the new right you know i
had to deal with some like the nazis and
one of the points they make is how come
everyone knows about the holocaust but
no one knows about the holodomor
and they're right we should know about
this because it is a great example of
both how the western media
were depraved but also what human beings
are capable of
uh and those scars are still you know
many americans think russia and ukraine
are the same thing
you know that like oh trump's in bed
with ukrainians trump's about the
russians they think it's the same thing
for us it's complete lunacy um but this
is the kind of thing where
pol pot is another example uh where
people have no clue
of what has been done to their fellow
man on the face of this earth and they
should know
how much of that do you lay at the hands
of communism how much are you with like
a
a jordan pearson who has as
intricately connecting the atrocities
like
like you're saying 1930s ukraine where
people were starved um i recently said
my grandmother recently passed away and
she
she looked she survived that as a kid
which is
it's fat those people i mean
just they're tough they're tough
like that whole region is tough because
they survived that
and then right after occupation of nazis
yeah of germans um how much do you lay
that
at communism as an ideology versus
um stalin the man uh i think you know
lenin was building concentration camps
you know
while he was around in slave labor um
i i don't i think it's clearly both
there are certain variants of communism
that were far like khrushchev you know
and gorbachev
uh the reason the soviet union fell
apart and this is kind of
i'm going to spoil the end of the book
there's an amazing book called
revolution 1989 it's like most beautiful
book i've ever read
by victor sebastian he's a hungarian
author and basically what happens in
1989 poland has their elections and then
then in 1990 they kind of let in the
labor people into the government
and people start crossing borders you
know in the eastern bloc
and you had hanukkah from eastern
germany and uh chances are from romania
colin gorbachev
because those are the two toughest ones
by communist standards they go
they're they're just escaping we're
gonna we're gonna lose everything
you gotta send in the tanks like you did
in hungary like you did in czech
republic czechoslovakia 68
and gorbachev goes i'm not sending the
tanks and they go dude if you don't sing
in the tanks
it's all done and he goes nope i'm not
that kind of guy
and they were right i mean they uh
coaches was personally shot
with his wife up against the wall
hanukkah i forgot what happened to him
but it they all self-liberated my friend
who was born in
czechoslovakia his mom was pregnant you
know under communism and she never even
imagined he'd be free and he was born
under free
uh and they were all looking around all
these countries that stuff liberated
because they're like this is a trick
right they're just they're trying to
figure out who's like not good
so that they can arrest us on mass and
they didn't so
although even within communism there are
bad guys and better guys but
we talked about anarchy we talk about
democracy do you see
like there's democratic socialism
conversations going on
in the popular culture socialism is seen
as like
evil or for some people great sure
what like what are your thoughts about
isn't a political ideology
evil so you're on the evil side yes
fundamentally
yes what what what is it
you know what yeah what makes it evil
what's like structurally
if you were to try to analyze like sure
this i say three ways
morally no person has the right to tell
another person how to live their life
economically it's not possible to make
calculations under socialism it's only
the price the prices
that are information that tells me oh
this is we need to produce more this we
need to produce less of this
without prices being able to adjust and
give information to producers and and
and consumers you have no way of being
able to produce uh effectively
efficiently
and also it is uh
it turns people against each other when
you force people to interact when you
force them into relationships when you
force them into jobs
and you don't give them any choice when
there's a monopoly the consequence of
monopoly everyone's familiar with
ostensibly under capitalism but somehow
when it's a government monopoly
all those economic principles don't work
doesn't make any sense but there's force
in democracy too it's just you're saying
there's a there's a bit more force
in uh and socialism yeah
but that's interesting that you say that
there's not enough information i mean
that's ultimately
you need to have really good data yes
to achieve the goals of the system even
even if there's no corruption
right you just need to have the
information right which you can't
and capitalism provides you um
like really strong real-time information
that um and if like
capitalism at its best and cleanest
which is like perfect information is
available
there's no manipulation of information
you